es ist früh am morgen und sie freuen
sich auf ihren einsatz auch wenn der
nicht für jeden von ihnen immer
glimpflich abgeht
davor der tierarzt am wochenende freuen
sich die tiere
es ist ein bodenständiger humor hier
unten am fuße des pixo mlu geografisch
und kulturell weit weg von paris zu
beginn der wildschweinjagd saison
zur sicherheit jeder muss eine leuchtend
orange weste tragen respektiert die
anderen nutzer der natur
nach der sicherheitseinweisung geht es
los roma will mit seinen hunden den
anderen männern wildschweine direkt wo
die flinte treiben oh
[Musik]
ja da vorne sind wildschweine
vorbeigekommen
mehr als eine million menschen in
frankreich haben eine jagd lizenz
deutlich mehr im verhältnis der
bevölkerung als in deutschland etwa und
doch sehen sie sich bedroht durch eine
großstädtische elite die alles
reglementieren wolle
land leben heißt dass sich hier
friedlich spazieren gehen kann auch als
jäger
das kommen aber auch viele spaziergänger
aus der stadt wir versuchen mit ihnen
aus aber das ist manchmal kompliziert
denn die städter glauben dass das ganze
hinterland ihnen allein gehört
nicht nur die jäger am pik sanlu fühlen
sich unverstanden seit der französischen
revolution ist dieses weingut im besitz
der familie
betreibt es in siebter generation
derzeit ist weinlese frost im frühjahr
hat die hälfte seiner reben beschädigt
da oben dem dem system noch mal hin
obwohl da höchstens noch mal anderthalb
fuhren drin sind ein hektar noch mal
drei stunden arbeit mehr
ein erwachsener harter beruf der sich
ebenfalls nicht gewertschätzt fühlt von
städtern ohne ahnung und achtung
die städte haben nur eine grobe
vorstellung davon was es heißt winzer zu
sein oder auf dem land zu legen
aber die ist weit von der wirklichkeit
entfernt
der winzer arbeitet nach ihrer
vorstellung einen monat im jahr während
der weinlese
aber das ist falsch wir ernten hier
gerade die harte arbeit eines ganzen
jahres
[Musik]
einige kilometer entfernt kämpft laurent
burri mit der technik her ist tun man
organisator und präsident des
stierkampfs verein some pics
die spieler versuchen dem starken von
den hörnern zu zupfen für jede gibt es
geld örtliche sponsoren erhöhen den
einsatz reich wie pariser fußballprofis
wird man damit nicht
[Musik]
der stierkampf der camargue ist eine
sehr lokale tradition im süden
frankreich sie unterscheidet sich von
der spanischen corrida denn der stil
wird nicht getötet die spieler müssen
gleichwohl sehr sportlich sein und vor
allem mutig das sind wilde tiere
wählt und rebellisch wie man hier sieht
auch
darin finden sich die menschen durchaus
wieder stierkampf ist teil ihrer
identität
mein vater war schon beim stierkampf wer
hat an vielen wettkämpfen in der region
teilgenommen seit ich klein bin habe ich
alle informationen verfolgt über die
abläufe der wettkämpfe
wir haben ganz andere tradition als die
da in paris so was kennen die dann nicht
sie haben wohl andere tradition aber die
teilen wir nicht
[Musik]
ein geburtstagskuchen in form einer gelb
weste
hier gibt es sie noch am ortseingang von
serview betriebe protestieren sie einmal
im monat die gelb westen eint ihre wut
auf die da oben in paris
[Musik]
es gibt zu viele eliten in der regierung
wenn sie mehr leute hätten die von unten
kommen ging es vielleicht besser weil
sie verstünden fragen sie mal micron
seine minister viele wissen nicht einmal
was ein baguette kostet
das sind zwei völlig verschiedene welten
sie haben das geld de medicis muss und
sie halten uns in der provinz filter
was als protest gegen höhere
benzinsteuern begann ist heute protest
gegen den druck der regierung zum impfen
der gesundheitspass bedeutet eine
diskriminierung das löst nicht die
gesundheitskrise das ist ein angriff auf
unsere freiheit wo haben wir dennoch
eine wahl
diese kritik am impfen teilen am pixeln
nicht sehr viele aber unverständnis
gegenüber dem zentralistischen paris
gibt es nicht nur bei dem geld westen
da drüben kommen die hunde die männer
mit den orangen westen und t shirts
schießen am ersten tag der saison kein
wildschwein aber ein schluss sitzt immer
der auf paris auf makro und seine
umweltministerin etwa eine ehemalige
grüne
die grünen wollen auf dem land alles
verbieten sie wollen verbieten dass
winzer ihre reben behandeln sie wollen
das betreten der wege verbieten und
wagen mit allradantrieb
sie machen komische gesetze da weit weg
in paris
wenn demnächst der französische
präsidentschaftswahlkampf beginnt auch
das hat tradition betonen viele
kandidaten ihrer verbundenheit mit dem
land viele hier glauben ihnen nicht
zurecht
sie kommen alle fünf jahre zur
präsidentschaft oder anderen wahlen und
interessieren sich für die nöte der
landbevölkerung aber den rest des jahres
hat man den eindruck paris steht im
mittelpunkt aller debatten dass paris
frankreich aber paris ist nicht ganz
frankfurt
[Musik]
verbunden traditionell selbstbewusst es
wird politiker aller parteien in einigen
monaten mühe kosten die menschen am
pixeln zu erreichen und wohl nicht nur
sie
[Musik]